MALE SPEAKER: To introduce
to you Travis Metcalfe.
He's the director of White
Dwarf Research Corporation
in Boulder, Colorado.
He will talk to us about
"Crowdfunding Astronomy
with Google Sky."
Here's Travis.
TRAVIS METCALFE: Thanks so much.
Thanks for the invitation.
Our organization has been the
recipient of the Google Grants
program since 2005.
And what I'd like to
tell you about today
is how we've used that to launch
one of the longest crowdfunding
campaigns in history.
On Valentine's Day in 1990,
the Voyager spacecraft,
out beyond the orbit
of Neptune, turned back
and looked towards
the inner solar system
and took this
portrait of the Earth
from the edge of
the solar system.
And Carl Sagan, the astronomer,
challenged us at the time
to consider this pale blue dot.
He said, that's here,
that's home, that's us.
Everyone you love, everyone
you know, everyone you ever
heard of, every
human being who ever
was lived out their lives
on the speck of dust
suspended in a sunbeam.
Of course, in the 25 years
since this image was taken,
we've started to find pale
blue dots around other suns.
And particularly, there's been
a revolution in the last five
years since NASA's
Kepler Space Telescope.
So I'd like to give you a little
bit of background on the Kepler
mission; tell you about
our crowdfunding program,
the history and motivation;
and then end with a look
to the future.
So the Kepler mission
was launched at night
from Cape Canaveral
in March, 2009.
This image was taken about
a minute after launch.
And you can see the trail there.
And the red points are the solid
rocket boosters that had just
been ejected at that point.
The telescope is about
the size of a small car.
The mirror is not particularly
big as space telescopes go.
It's half the size of the
Hubble Space Telescope.
And it was launched into
a Earth-trailing orbit
around the Sun.
So it just follows the
Earth around the Sun,
rather than orbiting around
the Earth like other space
telescopes.
By NASA standards, this
is quite a big mission,
a Discovery-class mission,
capped at $600 million
for the hardware and
launch and an operating
budget of $20 million a year
for the first four years.
Kepler's job was to look at this
100-square degree patch of sky
in the Milky Way galaxy,
in the summer Milky Way.
Here it's shown near the
constellation Cygnus, also
known as the Northern Cross.
Basically what Kepler did
was monitor the brightness
of 150,000 specifically
selected stars in this field
and just monitor their
brightness over time,
very, very precise
measurements of the brightness.
Because it's in an
Earth-trailing orbit,
it's too far away to download
all these huge images
all the time because it's taking
measurements for those 150,000
stars every 30 minutes.
So instead, it just sends down
little postage stamp images
around each of those
150,000 preselected targets.
And for a small subset of the
targets, 512 at any one time,
it would send more
frequent measurements.
The brightness measurements
were done every minute.
So you could do
additional science,
that I'll tell you
about in a few minutes.
So the basic
technique that Kepler
was using to try
and find planets
around these 150,000 stars is
known as the transit method.
Now, some of the 150,000
stars will have planets.
Some of those planets will be
oriented in just the right way
that from our perspective,
the planet will
cross the face of the star.
And these typically
take some number
of hours, these transits.
So for a certain
number of hours,
you'll see the star just
get a little bit fainter.
And then, if it's an Earth-like
planet in an Earth-like orbit,
it might be a year
later you'll see
the same event for a few hours,
and then again a year later.
So you have to have very precise
measurements of brightness
to be able to see such a small
dip from an Earth-sized planet.
But also very
consistent over time,
over a long period of
time, three, four years,
in order to measure the
orbital period of the planet
and get out to those
range of distances
where planets have liquid
water, for example.
Now, the fundamental weakness
of this method, the transit
method, is that
it only tells you
the size of the planet relative
to the size of the star.
So you only know the
properties of the planet,
as well as you know the
properties of the star.
Despite that limitation,
you can lump the planets
into large groups, with
uncertainties on their sizes
of a factor of two or so.
But even though
individual planets
you don't characterize
very precisely,
you get a good characterization
of the distribution
of planet sizes from
this sort of census
that Kepler conducted.
And this is the fundamental
result from the Kepler mission
from 2009 to 2013.
Before Kepler launched, from
ground-based observations,
we knew that big
planets like Jupiter
were around maybe 1% of
the stars in the sky.
And what we discovered from
Kepler in the last five years
was that Earth-sized
planets, smaller planets,
are the rule, not the exception.
They're very, very common.
So in considering
planets smaller
than about four times
the size of the Earth,
most stars in the sky
have at least one.
That's a pretty
dramatic transformation
in our view of how
common planets are.
So the focus of my
team is basically
to try and characterize the
host star of these planets
so that we can pin down their
precise sizes, and ages,
and other properties.
And we use a little trick
for stars like the Sun
to do that, that's called
stellar seismology.
Now, every star like the
Sun has an outer layer that
sort of boils from convection.
And these boiling motions
create sound waves, well
below the range of human
hearing, that propagate down
into the star and
set up standing waves
that you can view as brightness
variations on the surface,
exactly the kind of measurements
that Kepler is already making.
And that's the
motivation for Kepler
to be sampling at the
one minute cadence
because these
variations in brightness
due to the seismology
signal operate
on time scales of just a few
minutes in Sun-like stars.
So this is a close-up
picture of an area of the Sun
with a sunspot, the Earth
superimposed there for scale.
And you can see these
tiny little granules,
bubbles of hot gas rising.
Each of those granules is the
size of the state of Texas.
But those bubbles
rise and the material
overflows and propagates
back down into the star
and creates these sound waves.
So these sort of measurements
of the brightness variations
caused by the stellar
seismology signal
tell us very straightforwardly
the absolute size
of the star and also its age.
And you can use
that absolute size
to convert the relative
size of the planets
that Kepler measures
from the transit signal
into that absolute
size of the planet,
with a precision of only a few
percent, a very high precision
measurement compared to, say,
a 50% uncertainty that you'd
get for a typical star that
didn't have seismology.
So I'm going to give you two
examples of planetary systems
discovered by Kepler where
the seismology team played
a significant role
in the result.
The first is the discovery of
Kepler-37 a couple of years
ago, which is, in fact,
still the smallest
exoplanet discovered
by the Kepler mission.
It's part of a
three-planet system.
The largest of those planets
is about twice the size
of the Earth, here
over on the right.
The middle-sized planet
is between the size
of the Earth and Mars.
And the smallest planet is
smaller than the planet Mercury
in our own solar
system, almost as small
as the Earth's Moon, which
is just amazing that we can
pull out a signal that small.
The second example is more
recent, just earlier this year,
Kepler-444.
It's an ancient planetary
system of, in fact, five planets
that are all smaller
than the Earth,
tightly packed into orbits
that would comfortably
fit inside the orbit of Mercury
in our own solar system.
The thing that makes this
planetary system exceptional
is that we were able to measure
the age of the star as well.
And we found that the star
is 11.2 billion years old.
Now for context,
the solar system
is 4 and 1/2 billion years old.
So it's more than twice as
old as our solar system.
And the universe itself
is 13.6 billion years old.
And so this system,
at 11.2 billion years,
is almost as old as
the universe itself.
It suggests that only in
the first 2 billion years
or so of the
universe, you already
have the conditions that were
necessary to begin forming
rocky planets like the Earth.
And this has a huge
impact on the likelihood
of intelligent
civilizations to develop
because you need, as far as
we know, a rocky surface,
possibly with an ocean,
not on these planets,
but in planets that
were like them elsewhere
in the galaxy that formed
further way from their host
star.
But the fundamental
result here is
that we were able to
measure the age of the star
and suggesting that
planets have been
forming since
nearly the beginning
of the galaxy in the universe.
Now, Kepler has been
a spectacular success
by any measure.
But people forget that
it almost got canceled.
This is an article
from Space.com
two years before the
Kepler mission launched.
And the situation
at the time was
that the Kepler team was
behind schedule and over budget
by about $40 million.
And so they went
back to NASA and they
said we're just going to need a
little bit more money to finish
the project and it might
be a little bit late.
And at the time, Alan Stern
was a administrator at NASA.
You might recognize
his name because he's
the principal investigator
of the New Horizons mission
that just went by Pluto.
But at the time, he was
an administrator at NASA.
And he said no, we're
not going to run missions
with an open checkbook anymore.
Figure out a way to get
it done and come back
when you're ready.
They came back
about a month later
and said, well, actually
we need $50 million.
And he told them,
you have one month.
Come back to me with
numbers like these again
and that will be the
end of the project.
And so a month later, they came
back and said, oh, yeah, we
can do that.
We can make it in
the original budget.
And the way they
accomplished that, they
had to do to do two adjustments
to the baseline mission.
One was originally they wanted
a four-year operating mission.
And they scaled that
back to 3 and 1/2.
So they just cut off
some operating costs
off the tail end.
But the other big
thing that they did
was they outsourced all of
the stellar seismology work
to a European team so that
it would be done at no cost
to NASA.
So this put US participants of
that European-led collaboration
in a kind of awkward
position because we
were in this bizarre situation
where Kepler was collecting
these beautiful
measurements, but there
was no support for US
scientists to analyze them.
So that's what
motivated us to start
this crowdfunding campaign
to fund the work of the US
consortium of scientists
within that European-lead
collaboration.
And the concept
that we came up with
was basically an adopt-a-star
program for the Kepler targets,
those 150,000 stars.
Private companies
have been offering
sort of deceptive name-a-star
programs for decades.
And what we wanted to do
was compete against them
and undercut their prices.
And there were
three key features
to how we wanted to run
the program in what we
thought was an ethical way.
First, we wanted to be honest
about what we were actually
providing.
So we labeled it an
adopt-a-star program,
rather than a name a
star or buy a star.
So you can think of
it like it's analogous
to the adopt-a-highway system.
It's understood that the person
who adopts a stretch of highway
does not own the highway or
get to restripe it or anything.
But we post their name
on the side of the road
to acknowledge
their contribution
to keep that section
of road clean.
The second thing is that
the program is a nonprofit.
100% of the proceeds
from the program
would support
scientific research
on that same set of stars
that are in the program.
And finally, we wanted there
to be a direct connection
between the fundraising
mechanism and the science
that it supported.
So we limited the
adopt-a-star program just
to those 150,000 stars that
Kepler was actually monitoring
to search for planets.
Oh, I should mention initially
we just offered every target
star for a $10 donation.
But later, after a few
years, many of the stars
were value added.
We discovered that
they were double stars.
And so we started
offering those for $15.
Or there was a suspected
planetary system
around the star, but that hadn't
been confirmed from follow-up
observations from the ground.
We offered those for $25.
And then if you wanted a
confirmed planetary system,
it would cost you
a $100 donation.
So after a donor submits
a donation by Paypal,
or in the early
days we were also
using Google Wallet
and Google Checkout,
they get a certificate
of adoption by email.
They can specify the time
of the donation, a name,
or a dedication that they'd like
to appear on that certificate.
And by default, they are
given the brightest target
or brightest star of whatever
category they choose.
But they can choose
a specific star.
If they wanted to
choose a number that
signified a special date
or something like that,
they could also do that
And in addition to sending out
the certificate of adoption
by email, we update our website
every five minutes or something
to put that name or dedication
in the database with that star
so that each star can
only be adopted once.
Some of these
name-a-star companies
will offer the same star over
and over to different people.
And we thought that
was unethical as well.
So when we're done with
150,000 stars, that's it.
We're out.
Now, the centerpiece of
our crowdfunding campaign
was a representation
of the Kepler target
list in Google Sky.
Now, there are 150,000 targets.
And so the first
thing we tried to do
was just put them all in
a KML file and view it
through the Google Sky browser.
And, of course, that
crashed immediately.
But fortunately, Google
developed this regionater
software with a different
application in mind.
It came with a
sample application
to display the Swiss
national rail network.
The same sort of problem--
you have a big train station
with lots of connections
to other train stations.
And when you're
looking from afar,
you should only see those
busiest train stations.
But as you zoom in
closer and closer,
you'd see the smaller
and smaller towns,
with fewer connections.
So all we did was replace
the train stations with stars
and prioritize by
brightness, instead
of the number of connections.
Now, the green stars
in this representation
are available for adoption.
And the red stars,
we change it to red
once they're adopted so people
know they're already taken.
And stars with confirmed
planetary systems
get a special pale blue
icon in Google Sky.
Now although it was a
fantastic outreach tool,
Google Sky proved to be a
frustrating technical obstacle
for many of our users.
You had to have the Google
Earth plug-in in your browser.
And that was only available
for Mac and Windows,
and not for Linux and
not for mobile devices.
And so for many people, they
just couldn't get it to work.
And even those who did had
some difficulty browsing.
So a Dutch software engineer,
who experienced this problem,
decided to try to make it
easier for other people
to adopt a star another way.
And so he imported the Kepler
target list into a database
and made a simple
interface to query it
by the adoption name
or the star number
and to sort it by
different properties.
And he made the
code available to us
and helped us integrate
it into our system.
So one of the consequences
of this approach
is that each star then had its
own web page in the database.
So he included there an image of
the star in Google Maps, which
was a little bit more friendly
for a broader range of users.
And we included
basic information
about the star,
simple properties,
coordinates in the
sky, and a link
to download the certificate.
So this became a person's
individual star page
once they made an adoption.
This is an example of one
of those individual star
pages, the most shared page in
our database on social media.
Oh Se-hun is a member of
the Korean pop band EXO.
And so a loyal fan
adopted this star for him.
So by default, you see the image
of the star in Google Maps.
But you see we can
switch into the Sky View
as well, if you have the
browser plug-in installed.
And then we also
added this feature
that if you click and just
want a list of stars that
are close to the star
that you adopted,
then it shows you
where your star is
and several nearby stars, making
it easy for family and friends
to adopt a star next to you,
trying to make it social.
So this is a history from
the first seven years
of running our star
adoption service.
So the weekly
visits-- a visit is
defined as a session with
at least one interaction
up to 30 minutes.
And sessions that did not
involve interactions typically
exceed these by
a factor of four.
So it's reading a lot of
traffic that just bounces.
And on the bottom, the
corresponding number of star
adoptions during
that same period.
Now, there are periodic spikes
and there are episodic events
in this time series.
The periodic spikes come
during the popular gift-giving
holidays.
So Christmas and
Valentine's Day primarily,
where traffic goes up.
And the episodic spikes are
when either social media
or a traditional media
coverage of our program.
Traditional media,
typically when
our team was involved in
a scientific discovery
and we could issue
press releases
or talk with the press about the
story and how we supported it.
Social media more typically
by enthusiastic donors,
who wanted to share the
program with others.
Now you see there's a fairly
strong, but non-linear
correlation between
visits and donors.
And initially, we just
focused on driving
as much traffic as possible,
primarily through the Google
Grants program,
to try to increase
the number of star adoptions,
just by driving more traffic
to the site.
But in the last few
years, we've focus more
on trying to turn more of
those visitors into donors.
Now the three biggest
spikes in star
adoptions-- I mean
every spike has
an interesting story behind it.
But let me just
briefly mentioned
the three biggest ones.
This earliest spike
in 2008 corresponded
to a very short post on the
tech news website "Slashdot."
This was actually
before the Kepler target
list had been released.
And so we were just
offering star adoptions
to early adopters, who could
then select a star later
once the target list
had been released.
So there were no
technical obstacles at all
during that early time.
And nearly one in three
visitors during that spike
ended up adopting a star.
The second spike corresponded
to a traditional press release
that we sent out to
the media in 2009.
And it was picked up by
Space.com and a couple days
later by "New Scientist."
And it had actually
a bigger impact
overall because it was sustained
over a longer period of time.
But the most interesting
spike happened just last year,
last summer, when Ukrainian
astronomers adopted a star
for a not so nice nickname
for Russian president Vladimir
Putin.
Now, as intended,
our star adoptions
were indeed undercutting
the prices of competitors. a
And this led to a situation
where third-party resellers
began setting up
in other countries,
marketing the service
in a foreign language,
and then adopting the
star through our website,
but then acting as a middle man.
And then giving value-added
services, star charts,
and images, that sort of thing.
So this star adoption
came through one
of those third-party
resellers in the Ukraine.
We've also had third-party
resellers in China, and Russia,
and Italy.
After the Ukrainian astronomers
adopted the star in late June
of 2014, they
posted the image of
the third-party reseller
star adoption certificate
on Facebook.
And it went viral
on social media.
I could see that something
was going on just
by the traffic to the website
and the frequency uptick
in Ukrainian star adoptions.
But I really became
aware of the situation
when I got a call on July 4th.
The morning of July
4th, I got a call
from the "Moscow Times,"
asking me for comment
on the situation.
And they asked, now
than we knew what
this Ukrainian slur
actually meant,
would we allow
the name to stand?
And I told them free speech
is now written in the stars.
We have no plans to censor
any of these star adoptions.
We appreciate the
support for science.
There were some Russians
who were not very
pleased about that decision.
But so far,
nothing's come of it.
Now when we started
this program,
we imagined 150,000
targets, $10 per target,
we'd quickly raise
the $1.5 million
and have an endowment
for our research
through the life of
the Kepler mission.
And then in another
universe, that
might have actually
worked out that way.
And one of our early adopters
from the "Slashdot" post
in 2008 happened to know a
writer for "The Colbert Report"
and pitched an idea
to the show to do
a segment about our program.
But unfortunately,
they never did it.
I think they had a
hard time figuring out
how to make it funny.
There was another instance
where we were contacted
by a British marketing firm.
It getting ready-- this
was about five years ago--
getting ready to celebrate the
25th anniversary of the "Super
Mario Brothers" video game.
And they wanted to
adopt a set of stars
in a constellation
shaped like Mario's head.
That never came to
fruition either.
The client didn't go for it.
But if either of those
things had happened,
it might have given our
program enough exposure
to build that endowment early
on and support our research
through the whole mission.
Nevertheless, it was
a moderate success.
Over the first seven years,
we raised more than $100,000
through program.
Now just to put
that in perspective,
a typical NASA grant to
an individual principle
investigator is more than
that in a single year.
So we were just stretching
a little bit of money
over a lot of years.
But even so, we were able
to cosponsor, five science
conferences of
our collaboration,
including support for students
and early career researchers
to attend those meetings.
Dozens of students and
early career researchers
for each meeting were
supported by that.
We also sponsored
public lectures.
We paid publication charges
for our collaborators
in third-world nations.
So even though it
wasn't the $1.5 million
endowment that we
had hoped for, it
did provide some useful
support for our team.
So let me talk a little
bit about the future.
The successor to
the Kepler mission
has already been approved
for launch in August of 2017.
It's called the Transiting
Exoplanet Survey
Satellite or TESS.
And what TESS will
do is basically--
TESS will do for the whole sky
what Kepler did for this one
small patch of the summer Milky
Way, but for brighter stars.
So it will try to
find-- now that we
know the Earth-sized planets
are everywhere, very common,
it will try to find the nearest
examples around the brightest
stars in the sky,
where we can actually
have a hope of characterizing
those planets extremely well,
maybe even detecting
their atmospheres.
This is a full-scale model
of the TESS satellite,
with the core
science team at MIT.
TESS is quite a
bit smaller mission
than the Kepler mission was.
It's a Explorer
class mission, which
is capped at a $200 million
budget for hardware and launch.
There are funds in
the TESS mission
to build this spacecraft and
the instruments to launch it
and to operate it for
a two-year mission
and for limited
follow-up observations
from the ground to try to weed
out some of the signals that
could look like a transiting
planet, but aren't actually.
They're due to something else.
So at the end of
the TESS mission,
they will have a list
of planetary systems
around the brightest
stars in the sky,
identified and vetted
to some extent.
But there's no
funding in the mission
to do science on those targets.
It's kind of ironic.
They'll just release the
data into a database.
And they have a
similar arrangement
with this European team to
do the stellar seismology
analysis.
I'm not sure how they're going
to get the exoplanet analysis.
I mean just the transient
analysis itself.
This is one of four telescopes,
really large cameras,
that TESS will use to
scan the whole sky.
Each of these cameras
will basically
capture six times the
size of the Kepler field.
And there's four of them.
So at any one time, it will be
looking at 24 times the area
of the Kepler field.
And essentially
what the program is,
is to scan the sky in strips.
So it will look at the
Northern ecliptic Hemisphere
in these strips, 13 strips
during the first year.
And it will flip over and
do the Southern Hemisphere
in another 13 strips.
So just a two-year mission.
The cameras are arranged so
that they stack vertically
like this.
And the one that's at the pole
more or less stays the same
during each of those years.
So even though each
of these strips
is only monitored for 27
days, that highest latitude,
that ecliptic pole field, is
monitored for a full year,
continuous.
So the issue with that
is that much of the sky,
you'll only have
27-day time series.
And so you will
only get the planets
that are relatively close
in and go around frequently.
But at the pole, you'll discover
many planets in longer orbits.
We expect TESS to discover
thousands of new planets,
including dozens of planets
that are similar in size
to the Earth and in the
habitable zone of its star,
where liquid water
could potentially exist.
And again, there will be a
specified list of targets,
200,00 in the case of TESS.
All of those targets
will be monitored
at that faster cadence of one
or two minutes, that will allow
you to do stellar seismology.
But the orbit of TESS actually
allows for these full images
to be downloaded.
And so there will be
a 30-minute cadence
for the entire sky,
where you will actually
get all of those images.
And so some tens of
millions of stars,
that you don't
have to preselect,
can be scanned for planets
from those full images.
So as I mentioned,
the arrangement
with this European
team is the same.
And they'll just release the
data, after each strip in fact,
into the archive at the Space
Telescope Science Institute
and let people go with it.
And it puts us in
this bizarre situation
where NASA is essentially
launching a mission
that primarily European
scientists, whose countries are
wisely investing
in science, will
be allowed to exploit, with
no support for the US science.
Or little support beyond
the traditional programs
that NASA already does, nothing
specific to this mission.
So that's what motivates us
to launch a new crowdfunding
campaign, specifically for
the TESS mission, based
more or less along the lines of
the one that we've done so far.
We're trying to really get
the US community together
and behind this effort
so that we can maybe
get that endowment upfront
and get the science going
from the beginning.
So we have a consortium
of a dozen universities,
research labs, and observatories
coordinating closely
with the science
team leaders at MIT
and the Harvard Smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics.
And basically what we want to do
through this TESS astrophysics
group is to
characterize the host
stars of the planetary
systems that TESS identifies
during its two-year mission.
So we have started a project
on the Benevity website.
You may know that Google has an
employee gift matching program
through the Benevity website.
And just with the
200,000 targets,
we expect over the
lifetime of the mission
to try to raise $2 million,
$10 per star again,
for the TESS mission,
to support our research.
And that is typical of what
a large research group could
expect to get from NASA,
if they had any money
to give for a two-year mission.
If that doesn't suit
your fancy, there
are some volunteer opportunities
for trying to scale this Kepler
adopt-star program up
to the task of dealing
with TESS, if we are successful
in creating a larger wave
upfront.
One is we need to have
an integrated payment
system into our website.
We're currently using
a third-party provider.
And it's difficult
for our analytics
because people disappear
off of our website.
And we don't know why or
what happened to them when
they don't come back.
We need real-time processing
of the star adoptions.
It's currently run by kind
of a kludge of shell scripts
and cron jobs, that if the
frequency of star adoptions
goes significantly faster,
that system would break.
We could use some help
integrating social networking
into the website.
We're scientists, not social
networking or marketing
experts.
And we have limited mobile
adaptability to our website.
But it could also
use some improvement.
And finally, we anticipate
sometime in the next year
launching a Kickstarter
campaign to try
to get a little bit
of funding upfront
to begin hiring students
and raising awareness
about the program.
So if you're interested in
helping us launch something
like that, get in touch.
And with that, I would
just like to thank
the various sponsors
who have helped support
our program over the years.
First and foremost, Google
for the sponsored advertising
through their grants program.
We also get free
hosting from DreamHost--
it does that for all
nonprofits, as far
as I understand-- and
discounted donation processing
from Paypal.
We've worked with a local
marketing optimization
team in Boulder and
a few individuals who
helped us refine our
tools and presentation.
So with that, I'll thank
you, take questions.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that you're
looking for-- like in looking
for Earthesque planets,
that you were looking at some
of the largest suns or stars,
I guess, in the solar system.
So I was just curious, to
have an Earthesque planet
does a star to be a certain size
and where does our Sun fall?
Like how would you
locate it in the spectrum
of like small to large stars?
TRAVIS METCALFE: Sure.
Yeah.
Well, there is a habitable zone
around any star, regardless
of its size.
But smaller stars are cooler.
And so you just have to be
closer for that habitable zone
where liquid water could exist.
The Sun is a pretty
average star.
There are numerous
stars that are smaller.
But there are also
stars that are quite
a bit bigger than the Sun.
So it's pretty average.
Now TESS, for example, will
find-- because much of the sky
will be scanned in
27 days, they expect
to find many of those
habitable planets
around smaller stars, where
the orbits will be closer in.
And that's just fine because
it actually turns out
that smaller planets are more
common around smaller stars
as well.
And the smaller stars
are much less bright.
And so once you
find those systems,
it makes it easier actually
to use the techniques
that you can use to probe the
atmospheres of those planets.
It's actually easier to subtract
off the light of the star
and be left with light that
comes through the atmosphere
of the planet.
So in many ways, TESS will
actually position us really
well to be able to
learn quite a bit more
about these planetary
systems that are discovered.
In particular, because that
continuous viewing zone
at the ecliptic poles, that
corresponds to the place
where the James Webb Space
Telescope, the successor
to the Hubble Space Telescope,
will always be able to look.
And so particularly if
you find those candidates
in those poles, with
continuous monitoring
up to a year remember,
those systems
will be accessible to
the James Webb Space--
AUDIENCE: Do you expect the
star to go away, to die?
TRAVIS METCALFE: Which star?
AUDIENCE: Remember, those
150,00-some stars that you
have.
TRAVIS METCALFE: Yeah.
All stars will eventually die.
I mean some with a bang
and some with a whimper.
But only the most massive stars,
much more massive than the Sun,
like more than about eight
times the size of the Sun
or mass of the Sun, will
explode as supernova.
So most of the stars that
Kepler intentionally targeted,
stars that are
more like the Sun.
And those will sort of bloat
up into red giant stars,
lose most of their
outer envelopes,
as nebulae of hot gas in
space, and leaving behind
the exposed hot
white dwarf star.
That's the namesake of
our organization in fact,
the remnant in the middle.
AUDIENCE: Is it a long process?
TRAVIS METCALFE: So in
the case of the Sun,
this will happen about 5 or
6 billion years from now.
So it's a middle-aged star.
More massive stars, twice
the mass of the Sun,
go through that process
much more quickly.
So their lifetimes are
quite a bit shorter.
The lowest mass
stars, the ones where
TESS will find these
closely packed planets that
are still habitable,
those very cool
stars, their lifetimes
are very long,
longer than the age
of the universe.
And so in some ways that
makes them a really nice place
to try to start life because
they have a lot of time
to take root.
So a lot of factors determine
these issues of habitability.
On the other side,
you've got the fact
that those stars actually
tend to be a bit more active.
They eject material and harmful
radiation into the regions
around them.
And those habitable
zones are closer.
And so it actually
might be harmful.
And so one of the things
we're hoping to do,
in addition to
just characterizing
those planetary systems in
terms of their sizes and ages,
is to do ground-based
observations that
will establish how habitable
those planets are, really
beyond just the ability
of liquid water.
MALE SPEAKER: So for
your 20% project,
can people work remotely
or need to be in Boulder
to work with you?
TRAVIS METCALFE: Oh, absolutely
people can work remotely.
It's essentially a
virtual institute
already because our team is
scattered across the country.
So it essentially demands
that we all work remotely.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
very much for coming.
TRAVIS METCALFE: Thanks.